ground news is combating divisiveness in
media ground is a news comparison
platform that helps you see multiple
perspectives for any news story so you
can be more of a well-rounded news
reader download the free app at
ground.news
pacman all right let's jump right in
today many topics related to the
pandemic that we'll be talking about
we'll be talking about an anti-vaccine
hearing we will be talking about lab
leak but first let's just kind of reset
where we are
coronavirus cases in the united states
are now down more than 94
we are now at the point where we are
asking
with so many people refusing to get
vaccinated how much lower our case is
going to go because this thing is going
to keep floating around are we getting
to about as low a point in daily cases
as we're going to get anytime soon
because the virus is going to keep
floating around among unvaccinated
populations i think the answer is not
quite yet i think we'll still see a
decline uh but we'll know within two to
three weeks but we are down more than 94
uh from the case peak in roughly
mid-january now in terms of u.s
coronavirus deaths we are now down more
than 88
in daily deaths
still 400 people a day are dying in the
united states of coronavirus it's still
a horrible number but when we talk about
getting back to baseline risk uh i
believe it's around 300 people a day
over a year that during the average flu
season die in the united states so we're
getting very close
to that baseline level of risk that we
see equivalent to the flu
uh 400 is still high but it is the
lowest it's been during the the entire
pandemic you've got to go back to march
of 2020 to find death numbers this low
in the united united states now there
are many people saying and if you
emailed me you know david is this
actually because of the vaccines or is
this just because of the seasonality
because if you look at cases and deaths
last summer they were just as low and
that's not at all true so the first
question is
are the premises right and they are not
we are now at 14 000 cases per day and
declining
the lowest point last summer was 22 000
cases per day and they went all the way
up to 70 000 cases per day so it's not
even close it's not true
that cases were this low
last summer
now looking globally
cases are now down about 50
last week we were down 40 from the
global peak now we're down 50
from the global peak remember that the
global peak was about 830 000 cases per
day an insane number uh so this is
already major progress although there's
still a long way to go and many parts of
the world are completely or almost
completely unvaccinated and then
globally
deaths which as we now know
lag cases by several weeks global deaths
are down about 34
from their peak
we still have nearly 10 000 people a day
dying of covid globally
much of that is the unvaccinated
population but we are down from more
than 14 000 deaths a day so everything's
moving in the right direction
never as quickly as we would like but
fortunately vaccinations in the united
states are starting to tick back up
again after
months-long decline so we started seeing
this in mid-april
daily vaccinations peaked at roughly 3.3
million a day that was a very good
number we were hoping to get to 3.5 or
even 4 million a day but then
vaccinations started to decline and
decline and decline all the way down to
under 1 million vaccinations per day
over the last week
we were down last week we had a one week
average of 930 vaccinations per day
in a country of 331 million people it's
terrible it's pathetic it's horrifying
and we'll talk about the anti-vac stuff
in a bit
we are now starting to see a slight
uptick once again
back up to about 1.1 million vaccine
doses per day so
there will hopefully now be
the more reluctant people
who will start to realize maybe my
school is going to require the vaccine
maybe my employer is going to require
the vaccine maybe the vaccine will be
required to go on a trip to the country
that i want to go and visit maybe you
need a vaccine to sit in the vaccinated
full capacity section of your local
sports stadium and maybe that will
encourage people to go and get
themselves vaccinated whatever the case
one million vaccine doses a day just
isn't good when we still have so many
tens of millions upon tens of millions
of people who could go and get a vaccine
these are widely available there are
countries desperate to get vaccines we
have so many and yet one-fifth of the
population by last count just isn't
interested now one thing that does seem
like it will convince people maybe will
be full fda approval of the vaccines the
the uh the unvaccinated population
one third of that population says
i will be going to get a vaccine once
the fda fully approves the vaccines
remember right now they're approved
under an emergency use authorization not
full approval so
i would love to believe that as soon as
that approval comes one third of the
vaccine hesitant folks will go and get
vaccinated
i can't say i'm convinced i think it's
something that many of them are saying
right now
and then once that full approval comes
down they're going to come up with
something else now i also just disagree
with the premise of saying i'm going to
wait for the full approval before going
and getting vaccinated catching covet in
the meantime
while you wait for that full approval is
likely statistically to be way worse
than
the side effects you might have from the
vaccine before it's fully approved then
remember one once it's fully approved
then it will be the side effects aren't
going to change the efficacy is not
going to change uh but with the approval
coming it would be great to take any of
that anti-vax group vaccine hesitant
group off the table and get them
vaccinated if they're if they're
genuinely waiting for full approval
and they're really going to go and get
vaccinated at that time
uh great i look forward to them doing
that now
let's talk about one statistic
in the u.s that is pandemic related
that is really not looking very good and
that is that hospitalizations in the
united states are rising not overall
but in areas with low vaccination rates
now we've been talking for months at
this point in time
if 20 of the country never gets
vaccinated which the latest polling we
have is that 20 of the country does not
plan to get the coronavirus vaccine
what's going to happen well we'll never
eradicate it fully we may never anyway
but in addition to not eradicating it
fully
you're going to see these clusters pop
up
in the areas that have a lower
percentage of the population vaccinated
and
statistically speaking most of the
people who get it will be the
unvaccinated
but the vaccines aren't 100 effective
when we say 94 95 percent that means
roughly 1 out of 20 people who get
vaccinated do not develop antibodies so
these unvaccinated areas will also lead
to
some vaccinated people getting sick and
statistically if enough of them get sick
some of those people are going to die
this is happening now
we had the idea maybe that would be at
the end of summer maybe into the fall or
winter where you would start to see
these clusters they're happening now
there's a new new york times report
which says
in the u.s
hospitalizations are rising
in areas with low vaccination rates
health officials worry that covid19
hospitalization rates could increase
among the unvaccinated as variants of
the virus spread
the coronavirus might be receding in
much of the u.s this article writes but
it continues to spread in communities
with low covet vaccination rates where
highly contagious virus variants pose a
threat to those who have not had shots
as an example the article mentions smith
county tennessee only 20 percent of the
population in smith county tennessee are
fully vaccinated and there has been a
700 percent increase in hospitalizations
for covalent 19
over the last two weeks according to the
new york times database another example
in truesdale tennessee or maybe it's
pronounced trousdale
uh 23
of the population is fully vaccinated
hospitalizations up
700 percent
this is not a coincidence dr ted
delbridge says
in most age groups
people who become ill
are twice as likely to end up
hospitalized as people who got the virus
earlier in the pandemic what does this
mean this means that these variants
are not only more contagious but more
likely to make you sick if you were not
vaccinated so all else being equal
if you have 50 of the population
unvaccinated now
versus at some previous point now more
likely people are going to get really
sick and sick enough to get hospitalized
because of these variants
uh in maryland of those between 50 and
59 years of age who got coveted over the
winter 8 were hospitalized from april
april on
19
of people in that age group who got the
virus were hospitalized and the vaccines
protect you
this is not going to stop
this is not going to go away in this way
and i know that there's a lot of tough
talk about
i'm healthy
i eat a good diet
i exercise
etc
that doesn't protect you from covid19
uh and as the variants uh be that that
are predominant
are more transmissible
and or more likely to put you in the
hospital
you are taking a real big risk by being
unvaccinated but you were also putting
other people at risk at this point it's
like a broken record i don't know how
many times it has to be said
uh the vaccines are effective against
the variants they are slightly less
effective against some of the most
recent variants but you get really good
protection from all known variants so
far
if you just go and get vaccinated and so
we talked earlier about the numbers
we're now down to about 14 000 cases per
day it's it's really quite low some of
the lowest we've been at for for a while
um where do we go from here
where do we go from here if we continue
to see this vaccine hesitancy so a
little bit later we're going to talk
about biden's infrastructure
negotiations and some other things later
we're going to actually have video from
a hearing
where attendees were arguing
against uh any kind of required
vaccination and the nuttery is growing
significantly the nuttery is spreading
like a virus so we're going to talk
about that later we're going to talk
about lab leak but send me your thoughts
how low do you think cases can go
if 20 of the population really refuses
to get themselves vaccinated let me know
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back ground news is
one of the first things i would use to
get my head in the game
and prepare myself for the interview
because ground news is a news source
comparison platform that lets you
compare how outlets from the left right
and center are reporting on a story it
makes it easy to see the nuances of how
sources with differing political biases
are covering a story and it also shows
you your news blind spots stories that
your side of the political spectrum may
not have covered ground news can help
you build a well-crafted argument for
debating people you disagree with or
ground news can help you discover
something new about your own perspective
challenging your own strongly held views
on political issues be the most informed
person in the room download the free
ground news app today by going to ground
dot news slash pacman
remember that our program is mostly
funded by memberships from folks like
you who sign up at joinpakman.com you
get lots of great member benefits
including daily access to the members
only bonus show in audio and video
formats as well as commercial free audio
and video streams of the show
it's all happening at joinpakman.com you
can use the coupon code better21 to get
a membership with a discount so joe
biden is ending negotiations with
republicans over the infrastructure bill
and this now puts the possibility of
budget reconciliation in focus joe biden
got off to a relatively fast start
immediately signing a bunch of executive
orders on doing some of the nonsense
that donald trump did uh getting the 1.9
trillion coveted stimulus past not as
quickly as we would have liked but still
by washington terms relatively quickly
um and then
uh rolling out a very successful
vaccination program
but what is next and we've been talking
about well if it's not going to be
infrastructure it's got to be something
else that's big but infrastructure
really seems like the way to go
joe biden has been negotiating with
senator shelly moore capito
and some other republicans over
infrastructure legislation and cbs news
now reports that it's over
um
joe biden has said to senator capito
that the last republican proposal
doesn't meet the essential needs of our
country to fix roads and bridges it
doesn't prepare the country for a future
that will be reliant on clean energy
and it doesn't create jobs and this is
according to the white house press
secretary and so
what is now next and the answer is i
don't know
when you look at the details that have
been released of this negotiation that
joe biden had with with house and senate
uh lawmakers
um
the
he reduced his plan by over a trillion
dollars that's a big concession from joe
biden already
and then republicans came up in new
investments by only 150 billion and this
is the prototypical situation where you
negotiate and you negotiate and you
negotiate with republicans you settle on
something in the middle and then they
don't vote for it anyway so what was all
of the negotiation for now i am not
against joe biden doing some discussion
i think it's fine that he did that
because now he can say we gave major
concessions we sliced a trillion dollars
off of this thing and then they wanted
to give us essentially nothing and so
we're moving on without them i don't
think that that's a waste of time
what will become a waste of time
is now
if they don't simply make this happen
via budget reconciliation can they
actually do that i don't know i don't
know that joe manchin actually wants the
bill the way that it is and by the way i
mean from an infrastructure perspective
uh west virginia is a disaster
uh and by infrastructure i mean
traditional infrastructure uh like
bridges and tunnels and roads and this
type of thing uh but broadband
infrastructure healthcare infrastructure
educational infrastructure and on and on
if there is anybody in the senate who
should be desperate for the biggest
possible infrastructure package it
actually should be joe manchin but as we
talked about yesterday i wasn't kidding
when i said joe manchin was going to be
a problem and it's not even clear to me
that democrats have the 50 votes in
order to pass this via budget
reconciliation if we step back for a
second
i've gotten emails from people saying
is this something that can be done via
budget reconciliation sometimes you'll
hear some on the left say
joe biden should just do medicare for
all through budget reconciliation first
of all joe biden doesn't support
medicare for all but putting that aside
my best reading of when budget
reconciliation can be used would not
allow it to be used for medicare for all
that being said
there is no question that budget
reconciliation can be used to pass joe
biden's infrastructure bill with 50
votes in the senate rather than the 60
you would normally need
but that's only if you have all 50 votes
from democratic senators and it's not at
this point clear that joe biden actually
does the new york times also reporting
on the stalled negotiations not really
stalled ended negotiations saying
after weeks of failed efforts to bridge
deep divides the president pulled the
plug
turning to a bipartisan group to try to
salvage a chance at compromise my
question is how long do you keep going
at it from this approach because you end
up with what are sometimes these pyrrhic
victories where you do so much damage in
the process of negotiating something
that republicans will accept
that you are really compromising on your
ability to pass something that's
substantive and with the current
republicans as we saw with the covet
bill sometimes you spend all this time
negotiating and they all vote against it
anyway so my sense is that we're sort of
getting to the end here uh the new york
times writes sort of
pseudo-optimistically the breakdown did
not close off the possibility of a
bipartisan compromise entirely
and the white house signaled that the
president would continue seeking one he
shifted his focus to a bipartisan group
of centrist senators who have been
working separately on an alternative
calling three of them personally to
cheer on efforts and encourage them to
work with top white house officials to
hammer out a deal but even if the group
can agree on a plan palpable to joe
biden there's no guarantee enough
republicans would accept it
that that is exactly the point that
needs to be considered how much longer
are we doing this with republicans who
you know
it's conceivable that you get
i don't know
joe manchin and mitt romney in a room
and they come up with something that
they say they would support
but then do you still have 60 votes or
are you put in the position of having to
go through budget reconciliation and
then you're just arguing with your own
side you're arguing with joe manchin joe
listen we have 49 we need 50 what are
you willing to do for us and this is the
exact i mean when you talk about
the type of partisan
gridlock
that sometimes it's bipartisan gridlock
when you talk about the type of partisan
gridlock where the american people just
look at it and say this is why i am dis
i i am disillusioned about even voting
this is why we have voter turnout of 50
55
at midterms because
on the one hand we understand that every
two years we get to say we don't like
the people representing us in the house
of representatives every four years you
get to say that about the white house
every six years you get to say that
about your senator from your particular
state but then when you see this stuff
where democrats aren't even all on the
same page the things that republicans
and democrats agree upon they don't have
support for from the broader party or
you end up in a situation where even
those with the majority in this case
democrats
a slim majority 50 50 with comma
kamala's tie-breaking vote
um are negotiating against themselves
and will joe manchin vote for it will
cinema vote for it i get being
disillusioned with the system and this
is sort of like the worst of the worst
of the worst of american politics
i don't know whether this thing's going
to pass if you said you know take a bet
i think
55 45 something passes
how much it will look like joe biden's
initial proposal i have absolutely no
idea but i'm interested in hearing from
you
do you think this will go anywhere
remember when the republican party under
donald trump
completely abandoned even pretending to
care about policy and instead became all
about cultural issues and so-called
defending speech and being for speech
free speech more speech
and also
when they were against business
regulations
it was always complete and total
nonsense but it has now actually come to
a head with former president donald
trump actually cheering nigeria banning
twitter and facebook and trump
suggesting more countries should do it
and trump alluding to the idea that he
should have done it as president of the
united states whether he could have
actually done that remains an open
question
this is absolutely stunning
because it not only violates the
principle of republicans being about
more speech since these are speech
platforms after all
it also violates the principle of
republicans being against business
regulation because it is outlawing
if the u.s were to outlaw twitter and
facebook a legal business merely because
donald trump doesn't like what he
perceives to be the political leanings
of their enforcement of terms of service
donald trump put out a statement in
which he said
quote
congratulations
to the country of nigeria who just
banned twitter because they banned their
president
more countries should ban twitter and
facebook for not allowing free and open
speech all voices should be heard in the
meantime competitors will emerge and
take hold who are they to dictate good
and evil if they themselves are evil
perhaps i should have done it while i
was president but zuckerberg kept
calling me and coming to the white house
for dinner telling me how great i was
2024 trump asks so there there's a lot
to say here but here is the most
important point
nigeria banning those platforms has
nothing to do with nigeria wanting
twitter and facebook to just allow more
speech the way donald trump suggests
nigeria banned those platforms to limit
this free this free speech of their
citizens to complain about the nigerian
government that's fundamentally what's
at issue here so either trump doesn't
get it
or he gets it and he has the exact same
goals but either way it's absolutely
despicable now as far as the right wing
position on this stuff
wasn't the perspective of republicans
about this type of thing that if enough
people are upset with twitter and
facebook for as trump calls it not
allowing free and open speech wouldn't
people then abandon the platforms
and then wouldn't competitors arise and
it will all be resolved by the free
market as they love to say of course it
turns out that first of all
most people are okay with the
enforcement of terms of service by these
platforms people have not abandoned the
platforms in any significant capacity
and the alternatives have been terrible
we've seen parlor
gab i guess is a thing
mike lindell's platform frank's speech
which i don't even know if that was
online for more than 30 minutes
and then of course
are the facts about the platforms
look at facebook for example
the top posts every day are almost all
right-wing voices conservatives are
absolutely crushing it on facebook if
you look what were the top posts today
or this week it's ben shapiro right
winger it's dan bongino right winger
it's sean hannity right winger it's the
daily caller posts uh fox news posts and
occasionally a rachel maddow post makes
it into the top facebook posts of the
day or the week the conservative talking
heads
dominate facebook and yet they claim to
be endless
victims now one last thing on this
when trump mentions how mark zuckerberg
was coming to the white house and
telling trump how great he is
and that that's related to why trump
didn't ban facebook although he should
have
trump is admitting
he didn't try to ban facebook at the
time
because mark zuckerberg was telling him
what what a great guy he is and what a
great job he's doing so trump is
admitting something which we already
knew
which is trump makes policy based on who
praises him
and who criticizes him and who is his
friend
and who likes him and who does trump
like it's disgusting to hear donald
trump admit it but we suspected that
that was the case all along we're going
to have more on this story
on our instagram if you are not
following the david pakman show on
instagram follow us follow please follow
at david pakman show and if you want to
see a really wild and wacky piece of
hate mail i got this morning uh check
out my instagram david.pacman we'll take
a quick break
some really wacky anti-vaxx nuttery
coming up after this short break
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right so we're continuing to follow
the truly malignant growth of the
coronavirus anti-vaccine movement and i
have some really stunning video to show
you today uh this is real video of a
hearing in ohio about a bill which would
ban any ohio business or school
from mandating covet vaccination this
looks like a satirical show when you
watch it it actually looks like an
episode of judge judy or something uh or
or a saturday night live parody of judge
judy
but it's sadly real here you are going
to see
sherry 10 penny
who goes by doctor now she is an
osteopathic physician i don't want to
get into a whole thing about md versus
do
she is a do let's not even really touch
that right now because i will get a lot
of hate and furious people let's simply
say there are lots of reasonable dos
without question
there are also
just tons and tons of nutty
osteopathic doctors including quack
chiropractors and anti-vaccine nuts and
all sorts of different stuff
we're just going to focus on sherry 10
penny here
sherry 10 penny spent much of this
hearing saying we really shouldn't live
in fear of coronavirus
but then she shows up and spreads insane
irrational fears
about vaccines take a look at this first
video clip thinking if there is a if you
can think of any other product in any
other industry that has killed more than
5000 people stated in the vares database
and even if only half of those are true
200 2500 deaths in six months of use and
it's still full court press full steam
ahead so it makes one have to wonder why
why are we still doing this why are we
putting people into nursing homes like
that happened in new york and put people
with with known covet into place so
she first testified stop living in fear
of covid there's too much fear people
are too afraid and then she says you
really should be afraid of that vaccine
that vaccine is actually something to
really be afraid of
and then it truly went off the rails
with 10 penny claiming
that there is metal in the vaccine
which causes forks
to stick to your forehead she saw a
video about that on the internet and
then she also just ties in some
conspiracies conspiracies about 5g cell
phone networks so let's hear from dr
sherry 10 penny
and
some of the information that i think had
been discussed on your podcast related
to emf frequencies that was a thought
and and it was because now because right
now we're all kind of hypothesizing i
mean what is it that's actually being
transmitted that's causing all of these
things is it a combination of the
protein which now we're finding has a
metal attached to it i'm sure you've
seen the pictures all over the internet
of people who've had these shots and now
they're magnetized they can put a key on
their forehead it sticks they can put
spoons and forks all over them and they
can stick because now we think that
there's a metal piece to that there's
been people who've long suspected that
there was some sort of an interface yet
to be defined an interface between
what's being injected in these shots and
all of the 5g towers
not proven yet but we're trying to
figure out what is it that's being
transmitted to these unvaccinated people
how insane is this stuff how this really
should make us scared about the future
of this country it is shocking that this
person
was able to become a doctor of
osteopathy i have a hard time
understanding how she even accomplishes
simple things like how does she go
grocery shopping if her view of the
world is this ridiculous how did she how
did she drive a car to this hearing
quite frankly
later on uh one of the committee members
asked 10 penny this hearing was in ohio
remember
uh dr
tenpenny
how many people in ohio
uh where the hearing is being conducted
have died from being vaccinated against
covid check out how that went um
for the record if i missed it here or
there
um
of the five and a half million ohioans
who have gotten the coven 19 shot
through today over the last six months
how many do you believe have been killed
by that shot well
um
i guess i could i could just talk to you
so um
i don't know
okay so she's not sure she's not sure
how many people died
from the vaccine in ohio all right
is it out of line to say
that if she truly believes this stuff
she should be evaluated for
delusions psychosis paranoid
schizophrenia like is it i'm not
i'm not
joking about mental illness is it out of
line to ask that how is she testifying
as an expert on anything
never mind vaccines
so what's happening here to give you a
little background on the bill
is that republicans in ohio in the state
general assembly want to weaken ohio's
vaccination laws for all vaccines not
just for covet 19. so this was a hearing
about house bill 248
and the legislation would ban vaccine
requirements on customers
employees
or students from businesses hospitals
nursing homes k-12 schools colleges day
cares or others it would also prevent
governments insurers or businesses from
offering incentives for people to get
vaccinated or even requesting that
people get vaccinated so it's an
outrageous bill and again remember they
want to be about we're we don't want
regulation
except we're going to say
businesses would be outlawed from even
encouraging
employees to go and get themselves
vaccinated it's absolutely bonkers and
the ohio capital journal points out that
under the bill
if you are an asthmatic small business
owner for example
uh meaning you are at significantly
higher risk of complications from
covid19
you would have no legal right to require
or even ask that your employees or
customers that come in be vaccinated
you're a small business owner
republicans are all about hey we're for
business we're against regulation let
these small business owners do what they
want to do
they would prevent you this law would
prevent you from even saying because of
my status health-wise uh i am requesting
not even necessarily mandating i am
requesting that my employees or my
customers be vaccinated so this is
an absolute disaster that they are going
in this direction and look at the people
who are testifying here i mean it is
depressing that these are folks who are
increasingly having having an impact and
having a say
and if you didn't see if you just
listened watch the videos you see people
sitting in the crowd sort of nodding as
dr 10 penny says these wacky wacky
things
it is depressing to see
uh speaking of anti-vaxx we actually
have some i think it's good news anyway
remember that wisconsin pharmacist
who very early on tampered with 500
doses of the vaccine
making them unusable
he has now been sentenced to three years
in federal prison this is good news the
only question is should he have gotten
more time in prison and i'll talk about
that in a moment cbs 58 is reporting
that stephen brandenburg the
ex-pharmacist he is no longer a
pharmacist you will be glad to know the
ex-pharmacist convicted of intentionally
tampering with more than 500 doses of
the moderna covet vaccine was sentenced
to three years in federal prison on
tuesday
brandenburg was a third shift pharmacist
at advocate aurora health hospital in
grafton where he admits to intentionally
removing dozens of vials of the moderna
coronavirus vaccine from refrigeration
57 doses were administered to co-workers
before hospital officials found out
about this and destroyed the rest of the
doses the 57 doses were determined to be
still effective
and did not produce health effects for
the patients who received them at his
sentencing brandenburg told the court he
was greatly ashamed of his actions and
he took responsibility for them his
defense attorney detailed how his life
spiraled prior to the incident he had a
messy divorce he had mental and
emotional issues he had a sense of
disillusionment with work and with the
stress of the pandemic
but his former employer
was very angry and insisted he needs to
be punished that this has impacted
hospital staff who are now just trying
to rebuild confidence in the system
there that this won't happen again
government prosecutors asked for 51
months meaning four years three months
the judge said that the guilty plea
uh the lack of criminal record and other
factors
led to a three-year sentence
that the judge feels is just but not
excessive
in addition to being imprisoned for
three years the judge ordered
brandenburg to serve three years of
supervised release and to pay about 83
thousand dollars in restitution to the
hospital now this is just the federal
case there's also a state case related
to this pending against brandenburg uh
we will see what happens there so first
and foremost three years is this enough
time
um yeah i mean i guess so what what i
think about is
um
if indeed
so a bunch of these doses 57 of the of
the 500 tamper doses were given to
people but then the rest of the 500 were
thrown out this was really early on in
the pandemic this was when there was
really limited vaccine supply and they
were really only going to health care
workers and those at the absolute
absolute highest risk so
delaying 450 doses 443 doses which was
what just was thrown out due to the
tampering
um that realistically could have led to
some really high risk people
not getting their dose for a longer
period of time
and some of them could have caught the
virus and some of them could have died
now it may have happened or it may not
have i don't actually know whether that
happened i don't know whether we can
even say for sure
but
people may have or could have died
as a result of this
and so three years i don't know
what i do know is these people have to
be made an example out of now you can
always come in and say as as was argued
this was a person who was
not doing well emotionally and mentally
and all of the stuff and clearly those
were mitigating factors in terms of the
the the sentencing
but a signal has to be sent that this is
just an absolute no
uh this is i mean would we say it's
equivalent to tampering with medication
would it is it equivalent to
doing something to a medication you're
dispensing to someone who may be
seriously ill and depending on a
medication to stay alive would it be
equivalent to messing with the
medication doing something with it that
makes it not work or
uh dispensing the wrong medication i
mean it seems that it would be at least
at that level and it was deliberate it
was not an accident um i saw a funny
comment online saying
just another victim of cancel culture uh
he spoke out in some sense against the
vaccine by doing this and now he's been
canceled i hope that those are jokes the
these folks have to be made examples out
of
and uh threw away his career no longer
licensed licensed as a pharmacist
not good times not good times for mr
brandenburg but it has to be taken
seriously my question for you is
is three years the right sentence
prosecutors asking for four years three
months the judge saying three years do
you feel it's too harsh not harsh enough
or just right let me know you can
comment on this story on the david
pakman show facebook page which you can
find at facebook.com
show and don't forget
the second david pakman show youtube
channel which with
exclusive clips from the backyard garden
as well as from the david pakman show
live streams you can find it at
davidpakman.com
live
second youtube channel
barreling to our first 5 000 subscribers
quick break and we will be right back
after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show so fox news which of
course very loudly and proudly supports
the police as they say
is refusing to run a one-minute ad
which features police officers
condemning the january 6th
trump riots consider the absurdity of
this fox news has run endless opinion
programming opposing the movements to
reform police and certainly to defund
the police they invite endless guests on
to talk about how we must support the
police at all costs and the police are
those who should be given
leeway all the time period because they
are protecting our communities and on
and on and on and we should revere the
positions and opinions of police
and here we have capitol police officers
in a video
criticizing republican politicians who
have repeatedly attempted to downplay
the seriousness of the january 6 trump
riots
and they won't run the ad
check out the ad so that you know what
we're talking about this is an ad from
midas touch
i'm proud of the officers i worked with
on january 6th they fought extremely
hard our worst nightmare really come
true an attack on american democracy
right here in the nation's capital i
experienced the most brutal uh savage
hand-to-hand combat
of my entire life i received chemical
burns to my face that still have not
healed to this day i just remember
people still swinging metal poles at us
and they were pushing and shoving they
were spraying us
with uh you know bear mace and pepper
spray they were all shouting at us
calling us traitors it's been very
difficult
seeing
elected officials
and other individuals whitewash the
events that day or downplay what
happened as an american
and as an army veteran
it's sad to see us attacked by our
fellow citizens
[Music]
midas touch is responsible for the
content of this advertising yeah so
midas touch the company that produced
the ad
has said that the news outlet called
them last friday to tell them that they
weren't going to be airing the ad
hold on a second though fox was
screaming back the blue
and all of this stuff all of last summer
during the george floyd
protests and then now we have a message
from police
and yet they don't want to run it don't
they support the police i guess they
don't support these officers maybe they
support like the idea of the police
maybe and i'll actually get back to that
in a second
the details of the ad buy ben mizellis
who's a co-founder of midas touch
says they paid over 180 000 to have the
ad uh over one hundred eighty four
thousand dollars to have the ad run
from june 6 to 15
and that fox news never actually
explained to them or gave them a reason
why they were not going to be running
the ad
and we know fox news's primary
motivation is money that's what's most
important to fox news so for them to
turn down money
for an ad that somebody is paying them
to air
you know they are doing it because it
would turn their narrative on its head
and be completely devastating to them as
a channel is this a form of cancer
culture that they decry
they are canceling the views of these
officers saying we will not allow them
on our channel
can we sign finally stop saying it was
ever really about blue lives matter and
about police and defending police
officers it's time that we stop saying
that it was never about that
it's always been about opposing the
george floyd protests whenever you bring
up the blue lives matter uh movement
in the context of the january sixth
riots which was trumpists
overrunning
police
injuring police
they never talk about it in that context
blue lives matter and support the police
is only talked about in the context of
george floyd or those types of incidents
but when it's in the context of the
january 6 riots where it was trumpists
overrunning officers it becomes a
non-issue then they don't want to hear
it and so what is this really about what
is all of the support the police support
the troop stuff fundamentally about for
the right it's not about police's
individuals that's
the distinction you have to understand
blue lives matter is about supporting
and defending police as an
institution as a center of power
same with soldiers and wars
with the support from the republican
party of the iraq war in 2003 think back
to that support the troops didn't mean
support individual soldiers and make
decisions that will keep them safe and
out of harm's way if you care about the
individual soldier you don't send them
into harm's way to begin with for such a
hare-brained war meant to retaliate
against 911 which wasn't even done by
iraq you don't do that if you care about
the individual soldiers so support the
troops meant
i basically support republican president
george w bush doing whatever the hell he
wants
as far as uh troops and the military are
concerned and it is basically more of
the same with the police stuff support
the police
might apply to individual officers maybe
for example if an officer has been
charged in the killing of another
unarmed uh civilian then it's oh support
the police means support the individual
officers but now all of a sudden hey
we've got a group of officers they have
something to say
these were people that were there front
and center on january 6 at the trump
writes they have a message for us here's
money fox just play the message oh no no
no no
support the police means something very
very different then let these officers
get their point across
and there's no question about the
legality of what fox news did fox news
has every right to accept or turn down
any particular advertiser there's no
question whatsoever but let's not fall
for this bogus
back the blue
support the police stuff that they claim
because they abandon it like that as
soon as it's inconvenient to their
narrative
so let's go back a little bit now
to this lab leak stuff
republican senator lindsey graham seems
to have said the quiet part out loud
last night during an interview on fox
news's hannity program a lindsey graham
is a
big time donald trump brown noser and he
was brought on to talk about the
so-called lab leak theory of coronavirus
that the virus either originated in or
was being studied and then escaped from
a lab in wuhan china and lindsey graham
in just nine seconds really gets to the
core of the issue which is you know what
if it turned out that trump was right
about the lab leak which trump was
pushing absolutely without any evidence
for months in 2020 it would completely
change public perception of donald
trump's handling of the pandemic
overall
now it shouldn't and i'll talk about
that in a moment but it is absolutely
true that if trump happened to be right
about the lab leak it would change
people's opinions of trump and that's
the only thing that's at issue here
trump's legacy trump's reputation and
the optics of it so let's take a look at
look at the clip lindsey graham saying
the quiet part out loud here
why does this matter if trump was right
about the lab leak it would change the
image the public had of president trump
regarding the coronavirus more
importantly now lindsey graham is
simultaneously correct
in his prediction but also completely
wrong
that it should change our assessment of
donald trump's handling of the virus so
let's take it piece by piece because
there's really a lot here first of all
donald trump without evidence for months
suggested and implied and even said that
he saw evidence that the coronavirus
originated in a wuhan lab now
that has two interpretations
the most literal interpretation is it
really originated in the lab it was a
man-made virus not from the wild but
created in a lab essentially as a sort
of bio weapon now we've already received
countless expert analyses on this which
say there's no evidence that this was
man-made period there's just no evidence
of that
the looser interpretation
of it came from a chinese lab would be
that while it emerged naturally in the
wild so to speak
it was being studied in the wuhan
institute of virology's lab and because
of either an accident or a deliberate
act it ended up in the public now of
course the idea that china would do this
to hurt the united states
by creating a pandemic to hurt our
economy if that's the idea you subscribe
to i have a bridge to sell you because
this mostly killed people outside of the
united states this was absolutely
destructive for china itself so much so
that china has probably been lying about
their case and death numbers from the
very beginning
but then
we get to the really tragic part
if indeed a laboratory in china was
involved in the origins of coronavirus
whatever version of these theories you
subscribe to
and if donald trump actually had a
reason to believe that all along
other than you know just being
provocative or spouting off
it really should do nothing in terms of
changing our assessment of trump's
handling of the virus the lab leak
theory
has nothing to do with donald trump
completely failing to ramp up testing in
the early phases of the virus
it has nothing to do with trump
downplaying the seriousness of the virus
calling it like the flu and all of this
stuff
trump ignored the risks trump continued
to hold public events from which people
caught and ultimately died of the virus
as a result of those events
trump failed to set up vaccination
infrastructure and when joe biden took
over he was starting with essentially
nothing so on the one hand lindsey
graham is right
if indeed
it uh came out that some version of the
lab leak theory was correct it would
change people's minds some people's
minds about trump's handling of the
coronavirus but it would do so in a way
that is completely divorced from the
fact that trump failed on every aspect
of coronavirus but they don't care they
are
sort of playing for public relations and
that's exactly what lindsey graham
knowingly or not
is admitting here
um
he's admitting it and he's saying the
quiet part out loud and sadly it's the
truth and it's really just an indictment
of the sad state of critical thinking
that we have because nothing would
change about trump's failed handling if
this came from a lab and if trump knew
it or guessed it or happened to stumble
across it in some way not saying that
that's ultimately what we will learn to
be clear but it should make no
difference about our assessment of
trump's handling if you disagree with me
on that
if you think that no no no if trump was
right about lab leak
it would mean he did a good job on the
virus explain to me how okay go to our
website davidpakman.com
and click on contact us we have a
voicemail number and that number is 2192
david p
here's an interesting question about
the words we use to describe people who
do certain things in society in this
case specifically the sort of cue
trumpist people take a listen to this
yeah i'm just wondering why
trump and all these people that are
following him
and uh following cue
aren't considered terrorists
um if it was the foreigners that came
with that attitude would be
um locking them up
you know but these it's supposed to be
um terrorism within the country too
as far as uh
who it is that shouldn't make any
difference terrorism is terrorism right
these guys are terrorizing this country
the republicans and not all of them but
those that are following trump
and the ones following q and q anon
and trump and his family
that's terrorism we need to stop those
people i wish they'd just lock them up
it's the best place for them yeah well
so listen unless they actually commit a
crime
and many of these people have not or at
least not one that we're aware of you
can't just lock people up in that sense
but i think there's a really good point
here which is
if foreigners came to the u.s and did a
bunch of the things that the seditionist
the seditious
uh writers and q people and pro-coup
people were doing and saying
we would be saying look at what these
people are bringing from outside they're
coming in and they're advocating for the
overthrow of the government i think we
would be
obviously referring to them as
terrorists if that's the case
instead when it's what we have which is
you know mostly
white trump supporting men
um they're called militia
or they're called patriots or they're
called constitutionalists or they're
referred to as whatever the hell they
are referred to and i think that you
know to some degree we don't want to
overstate the importance of language
i've in certain cases including when it
comes to
we've talked about
latinx
as a replacement for latino uh or some
of these other things i've pointed out i
think this is a counterproductive focus
on the language
but when the language
is directly
reflective of a political movement's
priorities which is we call certain
people militia and we call certain
people lone wolves and we call certain
people terrorists uh we call certain
people immigrants but some are just
called expats right we've talked about
these things before it's not about let's
change the language because that will
solve the problem necessarily but let's
understand the way in which the language
is being used to propagate a false image
of what these folks represent in society
and in that sense i think that the
voicemail caller makes a very very good
point
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today i have to tell you we will be
talking about
i guess to inspire confidence in uh i
think it's blue origin is the name of
the the company
jeff bezos uh amazon founder is going to
be going to space on the first commer uh
passenger flight
for a few minutes we're going to talk
about that on today's bonus show we will
also talk about a u.s funded study of
wales hearing
that is going to go forward despite
concerns for the whale's health what is
going on here and what is being done uh
very interesting story and and i've read
a bunch of interesting stuff about it
we'll talk about that on today's bonus
show and also remember that coved
whistleblower from florida rebecca jones
um who was fired after
trying to publish the real covet data to
the dashboard of florida
she is now running against beleaguered
republican congressman matt gates and i
think that there's a lot of interesting
stuff going on they're including some
new revelations actually about
the circumstances of rebecca jones
firing so we're going to talk about all
of that on today's bonus show
how do you get access to the bonus show
it really couldn't be easier
just sign up at joinpakman.com that's it
you go to joinpakman.com and you get a
membership you can use the coupon code
better21 if you would like to get a
discount and if you prefer
if you already have an account with or
prefer to access the bonus show via
patreon you can do that as well
by going to
patreon.com david pakman show either
will give you access within mere moments
to the bonus show and also remember
make sure you're subscribed to the new
youtube channel we have a second youtube
channel now called pacman live
people are going crazy i've seen people
threaten to burn down their own homes in
a panic over how crazy this bonus this
new channel is you can find it at uh
davidpakman.com
slash pacman live we will see you on
today's bonus show
or otherwise on tomorrow's program
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors ground news is
combating divisiveness in media ground
is a news comparison platform that helps
you see multiple perspectives for any
news story so you can be more of a
well-rounded news reader download the
free app at ground.news
pacman